yo what's up is it Natalie Chopper you
can catch me on the bootleg calf podcast
you know what it is we always hear live
in effect you know what I'm saying I
think you know I'm a vet at this time
bootleg cab vet
bootleg cat podcast bootleg Capt show
special guest back on the show
my guy Emily Chopper Live in the place
welcome welcome welcome how you doing
brother good oh [__] God damn it just it
just slides right on we gotta glue them
on Jesus
um first of all uh congrats on
everything I feel like I feel like you
were just on the show not long ago but
dude yeah I think like a few months ago
a few months ago for sure a few months
ago
you've been dropping some good music
lately for sure lots of [__] singles
getting played on the radio yeah it is
going up is it I feel like you've always
had
like record sales you've always you've
gotten plaques as a kid like but is it a
little different now when you like
wherever you go you hear your [__] on
the radio because I feel like
do it again is like
probably the most successful radio
record you've had it is it's my first
one so like um it's my first walk them
down was one but do it again do it again
it's like everywhere Rhythm radio Urban
rate like it's everywhere so it's like
new it's still a new feeling so I I'm
enjoying it every time I hear it on the
radio like um I turn it all the way up
I'm enjoying it because it was times I
used to be like man I'm never on the
radio but now I'm finally on the radio
so I'm grateful for it yeah it's like
crazy too because like you're kind of
like you're you're so young but you're
kind of like like lightweight OG now man
yeah for sure
but the success I had yeah hey so for
the people in the comments we're gonna
speculate what happened with your chin
because we don't want people to think
you got you you uh you went you know
face first into the wrong thing you know
I don't know man I just be breaking that
sometime me too
as long as it's not the wrong breakout
you know so yeah for sure
for you you're obviously uh one of the
faces of Memphis Yeah so and you are
someone who we've watched kind of grow
into like to me one of the more mature
like
well-grounded like centered artists in
rap like I feel like you kind of went
from being like somebody who you never
knew what kind of [__] you'd be wrapped
up in when we'd open the phone so now
you're always spreading positivity
what would be advice you would give John
Moran right now John Moran um just
pretty much know like
all the things like that must happen for
you to grow and you know for you to be
more grateful
for for the occupation at hand you know
what I'm saying we gotta face adversary
adversity sometimes to realize you know
the power we hold and how good life is
for us and how much God love us so you
know that's just God sending a storm his
way so he can learn something from it
and once he learned it he gonna bounce
back stronger than other because you're
no stranger to like late night IG lives
that you probably regret yeah
I mean it's a pretty long yeah uh so
yeah that I just think like I think a
lot of people are being hard on the dude
it's like he's a kid at the end of the
day you know what I'm saying yeah for
sure man
um
still single yeah putting the stable
together and trying to trying to put
together to like multi are you gonna try
to do the you know the polygamy thing
yeah you know I'm still on that how's
that how's that like
going like you got to find a lot of
women that will be down for certain I
feel like women are a little jealous and
Petty to really like
polygamy lifestyle yeah I'm just letting
the economy I ain't really rushing until
none I ain't found nobody yet nobody yet
yeah but it is I got I got a few options
but I ain't putting on together toys
yeah because
there's a lot more I'm trying to focus
on right now before I think about that
aspect but um
would you marry multiple women at once
yeah like this is the crew I got six of
them yeah we hear this your room this
your room Tuesday you got me Wednesday
you got me yeah
Saturday we're having a party we're all
together yeah yeah something like that
yeah it's lit man when is the album
coming bro cause you've been dropping so
much heat so many singles I mean I know
you've been you know you've been putting
out a lot of music so the Body Works got
to be on the way uh April 14th you know
what I'm saying it's gonna be my best
body of work matter of fact
um got plenty of plenty of music for
people it's like 23 and then I'm gonna
come with a deluxe so it's gonna be it's
gonna be a big meal for everybody it's
gonna be huge it's gonna be my biggest
album the deluxe is already like you
already got all the songs set aside yeah
ready to go get it done something dope I
saw you do recently was you gave Lil
Wayne literal flowers yeah and I think
that that was was sweet because I do
feel like most of the time artists
aren't really appreciated until they're
not here or until they're like you know
for sure that's the main thing that was
a purpose what was the process like for
you kind of growing up and Little Wayne
is one of the most influential rappers
ever you know like working with Wayne
what was that like for you man man it
was like a drink untrue you know you
grow up listening to him you grow up
seeing them you grow up being inspired
more so than anything be able to share
the same room with them you know let
alone have a song with them in a music
video I just feel it was kind of bizarre
so um it was something I took heat up I
was grateful for I let him know all
throughout the through the night how
much I appreciated him just for him
being himself because um he inspired me
yeah you know it was he was drinking
contribution when did you like did you
guys get in the studio together is that
something that he knocked out and sent
back on no he just sent it back over I
got the verse when I was like in Whole
Foods and like did you listen to it on
the phone at Whole Foods my um CEO won
the records call me he was like um yeah
man we got rain on this verse I said
what nah I'm what's up
reacted very loud you must have dropped
your kombucha hey some dropped the
fruits I was checking out man it was I
had the whole store looking at me that's
what I used to call him fruit salad in
high school for yeah
shout out to Cyrus
by the way Whole Foods cut the [__]
check all right because I feel like
you're pushing a lot of a lot of that
lifestyle would send people the Whole
Foods to get the right food and [__]
they need to you need to get an
endorsement from them or Trader Joe's
yeah man shout out to Koya too you know
I got some smoothies and stuff inside
Whole Foods that you know I'm kind of
got my money in so shout out to coach
your brand what's the brand Koya they do
the keto shakes right yeah yeah those
those are gas you know my folks what's
better Whole Foods or Trader Joe's Whole
Foods okay and then you got everyone out
here
I mean wait what's everyone
you know everyone this is like this is
like the god of the grocery store it
costs a lot it costs a lot and only
there's something you should know about
me I'm really cheap I'm a Ralph's so me
I'll be at Ralph's I'll be clipping the
digital coupons
I make sure I put my number in get the
discount get my fuel points up so when I
go to the gas station I get like 20
cents off per gallon Whole Foods I only
go into the return things I bought on
Amazon I no longer want it's crazy
[Laughter]
listen do you want to win some money
gotta stop the interview but listen
there's so many opportunities to gamble
to bet on your favorite sports to make
Sports more interesting NFL season is
over but it's all good because the
opportunities to win are just getting
started yeah look there's so many things
you can do we're talking about NCAA NBA
NHL UFC boxing there's Blackjack
tournaments so much money to get in on
and check this out y'all if you sign up
right now using the promo code bootleg
do it right now you can get a welcome
bonus up to a thousand dollars plus
you're gonna get a free 150
000 March Madness bracket contest entry
that's
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
right now get a bonus up to a thousand
dollars you know to put in 200 bucks
they could give you 200 you put in a
thousand they'll give you another
thousand right look right now go to
mybookie.ag sign up use that promo code
March Madness is upon us so much great
Sports just this NBA season playoffs are
on the way man you could like literally
put together some crazy props like I
don't know over under on a player that
you like scoring you could do a future
on the MVP do you think jokic is going
to win it you think Joel embiid's Gonna
Win It Whatever It Is get in on the
action right now mybookie.ag with that
promo code bootleg when you sign up get
that free deposit bonus all right bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
also shout out to our family at hardean
Hardy in Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with
Jardine you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot him
a follow on Instagram while you're at it
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
so much fly gear so much fly weed what
are we talking about baby shout out to
hard Dean man that's the family man go
if you're in Vegas pull up on them man
Jardine Las Vegas uh anyway uh any other
features on the album that you can
reveal obviously April 14th is coming up
uh I could give one more I'm gonna do
Polo G Polo oh yeah that's my boy you
know we always got something we got some
version you know we got like three or
two Plex yeah that's like you guys got a
great relationship yeah my brother would
you like do a album together I'll be
telling them hey I got to get on polo
ass he know yeah we do that and then go
on tour crazy
I don't know it is I feel like it is
kind of like tour season for you it's
like the a tour following up after the
album for sure this is gonna be my
biggest album we're gonna have to go
somewhere we gotta go everywhere
actually it's gonna be that big you know
I'm betting the bank on for you like
going because I just saw footage of you
somewhere and everyone was singing you
posted it I think it was like last week
oh yeah my show yeah in North Carolina
Raleigh is it is it like
because I'm sure going and like
performing the new music and hearing the
kids sing it back to you has got to be
like there's got to be like a certain
hit of dopamine and high that comes with
that man it's crazy like I was stopping
in the middle of um performing I was
like looking at my DJ I'm like you hear
that [__] like it'd be the songs that
you
that sometimes like before you release
it you be like man that's the one and
then when you release it it don't be the
one
but a little bit later on it started to
be the one like it don't it don't have
that instant reaction you expect like
one song That Grew was like um I think
it slipped me out just let me out what a
time that song grew man and like when I
rapping now for the fans it's like a
whole
the whole venue saying it with you so
how does one get slutted out
hey you want to answer that little bro
I'll play a player over here
yo it is crazy though because like uh
I've never had so my son Millennium is
nine and I've never had him like ever
come to me and say he's like a fan of a
rapper but like you're his screensaver
on his iPad that's crazy for real yes so
on on his iPad it's like a picture of
you yeah and I was like That's my boy
that's crazy he's like you know and that
FaceTime I think you're playing
basketball yeah when we caught yeah he
like almost cried it was kind of crazy
I'm surprised he's been so composed
that's crazy yeah I know I was that much
bro he's like your number one like I'm
telling you bro he just be eating cereal
his iPad be playing just your tick tocks
on [__] loops on YouTube bruh that's
crazy now this is what's up man that's
why he was like he was like is mom
coming I'm like I think it's Mama beer
you know
his [__] mom's a celebrity over there
so when your mom put the toaster upside
your head how did that feel how does it
feel to get an appliance cracked upside
your head it feel good I like violence
you know I love that
yo
um do you feel like any I mean because
because I do feel like you are one of
the few guys who like is a good role
model for kids
um do you do you feel like there was a
certain point in time where you kind of
started to feel that responsibility uh
on the energy you're putting out in the
world yeah for sure like when um when
artists were rap to me my I mean when
kids was rapping to me my songs and when
kids was wanting to like get Nerf guns
just off base like when I was first
coming out how many guns real guns I had
in my video like nail want the Nerf guns
and all that so I started to realize my
influence and you know Nerf guns
graduate to BB guns and BB guns
graduated to the real guns so
it's just trying to fix that you know so
I've always like my music probably all
the time don't reflect the most positive
but me as a person I know like okay I
can give them that you know just like
you said he he look on his iPad look at
my tick tocks like he'll probably see my
music hear my music but he'll also see
right a goofy side a personality of them
you know that everyone has I also think
too like just like the when you do
interviews when you're like when you're
like I mean music is one thing right
like you're gonna you gotta Express
Yourself artistically however you're
feeling that day but at the same time
like when you sit down or you go on live
or you talk to fans you do interviews
there's a certain energy that you put
out there and it's always positive
always did you see uh NBA young boy had
an interview recently where he was like
kind of
communicate and how regret how he
regrets some of the [__] he's put it
into the air yeah yeah that's how I saw
it I feel like it's it's a lot of you
know I feel like we've watched y'all
kind of grow up man so it's like dope to
see kind of
because as a as an old head as they
would say I mean some of the [__] I'd
just be like stressed out for you man
yeah I'm like man these [__]
got B for everybody yeah it'd be a lot
of [__] going on yeah I mean it's
like I'm sure it's like hard to like you
got a studio session in the city maybe
you're not from like you always got to
be on your toe I mean you should always
be on your toes let's be clear you
should always make sure that you know
your guard is up but you know do you
feel like a lot more at peace now oh
yeah I always feel that peace you know
um I just know what a guy got over my
life I know the protection he has over
my life discernment and the intuition I
have rather is going to here going to
there or staying here or staying there
so never really like not at peace with
any situation because I just know like
at the end of the day I'm got it and
protected you know beyond anything have
you connected with glorilla yet oh yeah
we we've talked we haven't made any
music though I feel like you guys will
make a joint if you want to I'd be
trying to she'd be busy though she yeah
yeah she's real busy what is your diet
like right now I feel like every time I
see you you're you got some sort of
expensive water or some wild [__] you're
eating what are you eat like is there
like a specific diet you're on right now
a raw alkaline that that's the same
thing you're on last time so for people
who don't know what is a raw alkaline
diet so only fruits and like vegetables
and only things that's like raw and
alcohol so pretty much um nothing cooked
and uh no cooked food no cooked food so
it's just like salads or just no meat
fruits no Meats still vegan
alkaline vegan diet wow do you miss meat
at all um
how terrible is an impossible Burger
and plausible Burger tastes real good
actually I gotta try it yeah it just
looks good now is it good for you no
it's not good for it's terrible for you
but it tastes good though uh you're from
Memphis obviously one of the biggest out
the city but John Moran who's been in
the news recently uh has gone through so
I feel like some of the stuff that you
kind of went through early on in your
career would be advice you would give
John a rant man
um I always just knowing that um God
send you a storm for you to learn
something from it you know I'm sad for
you to overcome it and um for you to
have appreciation for the blessing he
gave you because he can show you how
quick he can take it away from you as
well so um he'll learn it quick and
he'll be right over hey we got to stop
the interview to tell you about our good
Folks at Blue chew baby that's right A
lot of people keep asking me does
Bluetooth work [__] yeah it does and if
you don't believe me they'll give you a
whole month for free right now if you go
to bluetooth.com and use that promo code
bootleg that's bootry.com promo code
bootleg you get a month of blue chew for
free delivered to your [__] house all
you do is pay five dollars in shipping
what is blue tree you ask well let me
tell you it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis in a
chewable tablet but it is discreetly
delivered right to your doorstep no
awkward doctor's visits imagine going
and telling uh an old guy about your
dick
you would prefer not to do that I know
I'd prefer not to do that you know but
you can do it all online bluetooth.com
you don't have to go to the doctor's
appointment in person no more no they're
going to send it straight to your door
all right your wife won't even know it
came your wife won't know that you came
and it came all right so what you do is
you uh you go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg and you get a month
of uh the whole thing for free that's
right a month supply of Bluetooth for
free straight to your door they also
just drop their new mint chewable which
is the same exact active ingredient as
Levitra so many options for you at
Bluetooth to make sure your dick is
right going into the springtime baby
look spring break's coming uh are you
gonna be coming
the real question is
is your partner going to be coming
not with the noodle dick
let's be honest make sure that shit's
hard as [__]
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and get a month's supply for
free and if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it's okay man
it happens to the best of us go to
Bluetooth and put a Band-Aid on that
thing bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
also
while we're talking about our partners
shout out to our family at Odd Socks oh
look at these Odd Socks underwear man
they're they're Half Baked
so much going on at Odd Socks uh so many
dope licenses man shout out to uh they
got Cheetos they got Jaws [__] Oreos
Cheech and Chong Naruto WWE by the way
WrestleMania is coming I can't wait to
see what dope WrestleMania socks they do
this year because last year they knocked
it out the park at Odd Socks look the
most comfortable socks in the world they
got The Odd Socks Basics that you need
on your feet uh all you gotta do is go
to oddsoxofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg at checkout you'll
save 20 off your total order underwear
socks
[__] hats whatever you need they got it
at Odd Socks uh they just got the
Coca-Cola deal so you go get some
Coca-Cola drawers Coca-Cola socks so
much always going on in Odd Socks I'm
gonna always say my favorites are the
WWE in the Breaking Bad Ones
um so go to oddsocksofficial.com right
now use that promo code bootleg and you
will save 20 off at checkout shout out
to them most comfortable socks in the
world crazy comfortable underwear my
goodness if you ain't got Odd Socks on
your feet and ass what are you doing out
in these streets all right go to
hotsocksofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off let's get back to the
interview in your opinion who is kind of
like you know I feel like Memphis is uh
you know it's one of them it's the city
in hip-hop right now
um
who's the hottest in Memphis outside of
yourself right now so
you gotta go at all Florida for sure
it's big glow right this was So Glorious
she's hilarious for sure you interview
her now yeah yeah I think we ate Edibles
or no we didn't eat Edibles we
I gave her some wax we were [__] hot
it was it was one of the funnier
interviews I've ever done shout out to
Glory yeah I think I saw that I saw a
few clips from me um all right so we got
Polo G we got little Wayne's on the
album right yeah Polo cheese on the
album uh anybody from Memphis
uh
uh I can't get too many so money back
goes on the album
um
I can't get too many I'm Gonna Keep
fishing no no no April 14th I'm gonna
say no even if you get it right now who
is the what's the name of the title oh
yeah Cottonwood too
there it is yes sir I went to April 14th
April 14th man uh anything else coming
we've got a remix to do it again yet
um I got one I did one with a turkey
artist
um from Turkey yeah
a hair transplant at the same time nah
we donated some stuff to Turkey too for
the earthquake yeah so it was real dope
shout out to Turkey man that's also the
hair transplant capital of the world
from what I hear
like if you're bald you go to Turkey so
like this guy this senior citizen that's
been taking you to radio stations
because look at that he looks like Cuba
Gooding Jr let himself go
uh anything else you got on the way man
uh March 10th you know we dropping um
I'm dropping a new song called more up
front pretty much meaning like you know
the gist of it is if you if you you know
people been showing your word if you
need some more of it you know I'm saying
people been showing you love respect or
whatever you need some more in front of
it you know so that's the gist it's a
it's a banger it's a slapper new records
um
hey if you could do a collab album with
anybody outside of Polo G who would it
be
Drake Drake that'd be crazy that would
be crazy that'd be hard have you linked
with Drake not yet you haven't met him
um we're gonna make that happen oh me
yeah that'd be crazy man all right well
[__] I appreciate you pulling up as
always brother analy Chopper look at the
album April 14th Cottonwood too let's do
it boom
oh wait wait wait wait one more question
oh yeah come over here
move them feet you gotta come ask her
right yeah
ask her right here all right
out of all the rappers you've collabed
with what which one was your favorite
did you think of that or somebody told
you that I thought about it
all the rappers I've collabed with who's
my favorite
I gotta go a little easy like without a
doubt Weezy have baby Wheezy man he
the same way that I that I gave him
flowers and show my appreciation he
literally showed it like back that stuff
and that was like um it was rare
uh he text me out of nowhere he got my
number he check up on me he'll text me
every other any like any other day out
of the Blues just ask how I'm doing I've
never met someone of that caliber that
that much of a goat he's the greatest to
be so um humble he reminded me of myself
so Boom the Millennium question can
concludes the interview